um well unfortunately I I've been on
your show twice in recent weeks about
strikes in the Civil Service uh we've
been seeing strikes now since December
including two national walkouts of over
130 000 people across 130 different
government departments but unfortunately
since I've been on your show okay I can
tell you there has not been one minute
of negotiations with the government or
their representatives and therefore this
strike is a significant escalation
because the government's own Workforce
are living in in work poverty forty
thousand using food banks 45 000
claiming in work benefits and now an
estimated 60 to 70 000 on the national
minimum wage because of pay cuts in the
last decade and if the government can
talk to the Health Service and I'm glad
they did to teachers and I'm glad they
did to Firefighters and I'm glad they
did surely the question must be asked
why are we now seeing this level of
strikes and still the government will
not pick up the phone and have a single
minute of talks to the this disruption
maybe it's because the government says
that um the strike is not going to have
any impact on people uh wanting to apply
for a new passport and they're not
changing uh their guidance and advice
which says uh wait 10 weeks for a
passport
well they they may be saying that I I
think even if that's what was the case
and we will see we don't believe that
will be the case it's still frankly
astonishing that the government who
knows his own workers are claiming
benefits and using food banks and
delivering Frontline services are
getting a two percent pay award when
food inflation is 18 and as the piece
you've just done people are facing a
cost of living crisis the reality is
today okay what we're going to see is
every passport in the UK every passport
office there are 1900 staff directly
involved in decision making on new
passports renewal applications and
sitting on reception areas of those 1600
will be on strike that's about 85
percent of the workers involved so it's
inevitable that delays will increase
cues will increase in fact we saw cues
outside offices when strikes were
announced let alone when they started
and all of this the government knew was
coming I contacted them three weeks ago
and yeah this absolute radio silence
I've been sitting by the phone I'm
sitting here waiting today for Jeremy
Quinn or any government minister to say
let's have the same type of talks we've
had elsewhere and if they don't do that
okay I'm sad to say that we won't just
see five weeks of strikes in the
passport offices in the next two weeks
you'll see the British Library closed
you'll see the British Museum closed
you'll see more strikes in the
department for transport including
driving examiners and it goes on and on
why because
sorry to interrupt sorry about people at
home what they will be asking this
morning is if I'm applying for my
passport what impact will this strike
have what impact will it have in your
opinion
well in my opinion there will be huge
delays in the already 10 weeks that
people are supposed to apply for
passports and there will be huge
disruption on The Fast Track service
that people can use when they want to
get a passport quicker now the
government says it's got contingency
measures in place so we'll see how that
works out over the next few days and
weeks but I would expect there to be
delays and yet there shouldn't be a
single delay if the passport offices
will give more than a two percent pay
raise and given the resources they need
we would have a far better service in
normal times let alone the disruption
we're going to see over this five weeks
so it would be great if people could get
the government on the media today just
to ask them a simple question why is it
that the people you clapped in the
pandemic who delivered the furlough
scheme delivered three million claims to
Universal Credit delivered passports and
driving licenses kept our borders safe
and our prisons running
why did you clap them in the pandemic
now you're giving them less than any
other worker in the public sector and
you won't even deem yourself to take the
time to get into talks is frankly
astonishing